nicola was du eigentlich
rebellischer teenager komplett nicht ich
war ja die volle streberin ich glaube
keine mutter dieser welt hatte so ein
nettes textdateien die nicht
so dass jetzt ich war total rebellisch
zum beispiel habe ich immer dennis
geschaut
ich musste mich dass das rebellische ja
für meine eltern war schon ein akt der
rebellion der liste seien ja auch eine
überleitung zu jonathan franzen und ich
habe 80er jahre ja das stimmt aber es
geht auch um eine familiengeschichte
genau aber das ist ja eine
pastorenfamilie das ist jetzt nicht also
wenn du mit diesen alten bemerkungen
nicht aufhörst dann kommen wir nun ich
habe das gefühl du warst noch
eine person die dieses buch gar nicht
gelesen haben pastor us und seine frau
marion und sie haben vier kinder in
unterschiedlichen teenager phasen und
alle sind eigentlich ein bisschen auf
der suche nach dem richtigen leben und
ihr resultieren die denn also der
älteste sohn klein ist eigentlich am
studieren und deswegen freigestellt und
muss nicht nach vietnam und dann
überlegt er sich aber dass er sich
freiwillig einziehen lassen wir
beziehungsweise ein studium unterbricht
um in den krieg zu ziehen klar sagt weil
ich nicht in den krieg gehe müssen
weniger privilegierte mitglieder meines
jahrgangs in den krieg gehen die ihm
nicht studieren können deswegen keine
gründe haben das sofort so ist es keine
revolte gegen die l jahr dann sagt aber
herr frentzen das ist nur ein
vorgeschobener grund in wahrheit geht es
ihnen sehr wohl darum dass er weiß dass
er seinen vater dadurch wirklich
verstören kann das interessante ist dass
es ja auch immer bei entscheidungen und
darum geht es in dem buch ganz oft
verschiedene ebenen gibt es gibt hier
auch entscheidung die seen moralisch
integer aus aber sind vom antrieb her
eigentlich fragwürdig es ist sozusagen
eine alte grundsatz frage der
philosophie was ist eigentlich wichtig
für die bewertung irgendeiner handlung
ist die handlung selbst es ist die
handlungs folge oder es ist der antrieb
kenner und dieses thema wird
leitmotivisch eigentlich anhand von
allen figuren in diesem roman wieder und
wieder durchgespielt was wäre denn deine
persönliche antwort geht es darum die
handlung selbst oder geht es darum aus
welchen gründen man die handlung macht
also wenn zum beispiel mir meine
hautärztin sagt die ihre ganzen teuren
kosmetika schenken sie ihrer bitte ihrer
feindin weil die sind zwar teurer aber
schädlich dann wundere ich mich erst mal
warum ich die noch nicht geschenkt
bekommen haben also tugend ethik würde
sagen es geht nur um seinen antriebs und
ich wollte aber wissen was du sagst
nicht tun und ethik ich würde sagen
möchtest dich irgendwo hinein ich finde
ich fürchte mich nicht sondern ich finde
das eine sehr herausfordernde frage wie
ich sie von einem schockierend
oberflächlichen münchen wie dir gar
nicht erwartet hätte also grenzen
beantwortet diese frage auch nicht
frentzen bietet keine lösung im sinne
von das ist die richtige art und weise
sein leben zu führen wenn ich ja immer
gut ja das finde ich auch gut wäre
berlin man heute was die heutige
gesellschaft auszeichnet ist dass sie
sehr viel stärker funktioniert über
ideen von zugehörigkeit dann ist
natürlich auch der akt der rebellion gar
nicht mehr im vordergrund weil bei
rebellion geht es ja um abgrenzung das
heißt die missbilligung von anderen
milieus gar nicht mehr relevant ist das
finde ich jetzt wirklich einen super
interessanten gedanken von philipp
tingler hat hätte ich auch in drei
sekunden sagen können naja ich brauche
halt immer ein bisschen länger
[Musik]